vamos a volver a hablar de él
[Música]
pero creedme este vídeo es especial
porque hay algo que todavía nadie ha
contado cómo funciona la sanidad en
china hasta qué punto el sistema de
salud chino ha podido contribuir a que
surja la pandemia que está asolando el
planeta en el año 2020 si este vídeo es
un poco más largo pero al final
entenderéis porque merece la pena
dedicarle tiempo de vuestra cuarentena a
este tema así que vamos con ello
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la pregunta que nos haremos todos dentro
de 30 años será dónde estabas cuando las
cuarentenas del coronavirus y
probablemente todos recordaremos
imágenes como esta
china manda doctores y mascarillas del
extranjero después de que las
infecciones domésticas caigan exacto
todos hemos visto las noticias de china
enviando ayuda a los países europeos en
muchos medios ya hablan de lo
responsable que ha sido el gobierno
chino atajando los contagios del
coronavirus todo un ejemplo para el
mundo y por supuesto que hay muchas
cosas que podemos aplaudir de china sin
embargo hay una duda que todavía queda
pendiente cómo funciona el sistema de
salud chino hasta qué punto la crisis
del coronavirus podría ser el chernóbil
del régimen de beijing
[Música]
por ejemplo no es ningún secreto que las
regulaciones sanitarias chinas son
prácticamente inexistentes cualquiera
que haya viajado a china ha podido ver
de primera mano los mercadillos
callejeros donde se manipula comida sin
guantes y apenas hay inspecciones de
sanidad pero en visual política
queríamos ir mucho más allá así que nos
pusimos a investigar a fondo el sistema
de salud chino y creedme os va a
sorprender
porque la pregunta que nos hacemos es la
mala fama que tienen los controles
sanitarios en china es real porque los
chinos no quieren ir al médico y lo que
es más importante tiene alguna
responsabilidad del partido comunista
chino en la expansión del coronavirus
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero como esto es un tema que tiene
mucha parte de medicina vamos a contar
con un buen amigo que nos va a asesorar
nada más y nada menos que han guiado
radwán del canal glóbulo azul hola
fonseca y un abrazo enorme a todos los
seguidores de visual político preparados
porque el vídeo de hoy va a subir la
temperatura pero antes de seguir tengo
que contaros una cosa algo que muchos ya
sabéis y es que la familia de visual
política ha tenido un nuevo hermanito
con dimensión mixta cruise line si os
presento a visual político touch es
decir la versión alemana de visual
polític presentada por el hombre más
parecido a arnold schwarzenegger que he
visto en mi vida nuestro buen amigo marc
geiger a partir de ahora ya podéis
practicar la lengua de ramstein viendo
todos nuestros vídeos en alemán y por
supuesto si tenéis un amigo alemán pasa
el enlace para que pueda conocernos en
la descripción tenéis todos los detalles
y ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los médicos descalzos en el año 1949 mao
zedong se hace con el gobierno de china
y se encuentra con un país enorme y
atrasado en el tiempo en la mayor parte
del país hablar de hospitales modernos
era como hablarles de internet y como no
había recursos para formar y enviar
médicos por todo el país
mao inventó el llamado programa de los
médicos descalzos básicamente los
médicos descalzos eran los chavales más
espabilados de cada aldea
[Música]
se los llevaron seis meses a enseñarles
unas nociones básicas de medicina y al
atender a tus vecinos por raro que suene
este programa funcionó muy bien por lo
mucho que extendió los cuidados médicos
el programa alcanzó al 90% de china sus
conocimientos médicos no eran profundos
pero prestaban tres servicios básicos
asistir en los partos lo que redujo la
mortalidad infantil lograr que la
vacunación fuera masiva algo vital para
prevenir las enfermedades infecciosas y
mejorar la información sobre los hábitos
de higiene de la población que es la
forma de contener las posibles epidemias
y si la idea funciona muy bien pero a
medida que china se hacía más rica
necesitaba un sistema sanitario en
condiciones
[Música]
en los años 80 y 90 den xiaoping abrió
poco a poco la economía china todo esto
ha traído una enorme prosperidad a los
chinos pero no todo ha mejorado hay dos
áreas donde china va de mal en peor el
medio ambiente y el sistema sanitario
[Música]
y los costes de la atención médica en
china obligan a los pacientes a
endeudarse pensando bien china quería
tecnología y medicina moderna lo antes
posible para eso ya no valía con los
médicos descalzos necesitaban hospitales
y la forma más rápida y competitiva de
conseguir tener hospitales en tu país
era con el libre mercado el problema
pues el problema os lo podéis imaginar
ya mismo por supuesto que china ha
crecido una barbaridad pero ha crecido
de forma desigual hacia el año 2000
solamente el 30 por ciento de la
población de china tenía seguro médico
el resto tenía que ir siempre con los
guantes por delante
una consulta médica equivalía a un mes
de salario además en las zonas rurales
la atención dejaba bastante que desear
así que los chinos preferían ir al
hospital de la ciudad por una semana
hospitalizado la factura ya se iba a los
tres meses de salario china es el único
país de asia oriental que depende de que
los pacientes paguen las vacunas
infantiles ante este panorama han
regresado enfermedades que china llegó a
tener bajo control es el caso de la
tuberculosis el sarampión y la fiebre
del caracol lo peor para los chinos es
que la atención sanitaria les cuesta un
ojo de la cara y encima tienen que untar
al médico si quieren que les trate bien
un médico chino recibió sobornos por más
de 18 millones de dólares sin embargo
las cosas han cambiado en los últimos 10
años como pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
e
y agra del himalaya el coronavirus no es
la primera epidemia que sufren en china
en 2003 tuvieron la crisis del sars en
aquel momento pese a que el sistema
fuera privado el gobierno dio
tratamiento gratis a todos los afectados
y diréis bueno pues no hay problema si
el gobierno pagaba el tratamiento todos
estaban cubiertos verdad pues si el
problema es que el gobierno solo pagaba
el tratamiento por fax es decir que si
tú ibas al médico pensando que tenías
ars pero tenías una gripe normal te
tocaba pagar la factura conclusión mucha
gente no iba al médico y como podéis
imaginar el hecho de que la gente no se
atreviera a ir al médico es un problema
por un lado el gobierno chino ayuda a
pagar los gastos sanitarios por el otro
tienen que controlar los gastos que
ocurre entonces
pues veréis el estado pone límites a la
cantidad de tratamientos subvencionados
es el límite son 1700 dólares eso es lo
máximo que un hospital puede reclamar al
gobierno en los hospitales rurales este
límite es incluso más bajo pero y esto
en que se traduce pues en que a partir
de dos semanas de tratamiento los
hospitales dan de baja a casi todos los
enfermos estén o no estén completamente
sanos por otro lado los hospitales están
incentivados para dejar que los
pacientes con enfermedades leves se
queden más tiempo de lo que deberían de
esta forma puedan justificar el cobro de
esos 1.700 dólares de subvención máxima
así que en el año 2009 china volvió a
reformar su sistema sanitario y a día de
hoy el 95 por ciento de la población
tiene seguro médico y diréis pues bien
problema resuelto verdad puedes esperar
un momento porque aquí viene el primer
problema en china el estado cubre entre
el 50 y el 75 por ciento de los costes
sanitarios esto significa que si tienes
una enfermedad grave con un tratamiento
caro sigues teniendo que pagar y
obviamente no todo el mundo puede
hacerlo en realidad el sistema sanitario
chino combina lo peor de ambos mundos lo
peor de un sistema privado con lo peor
de un sistema público
[Aplausos]
por un lado el gobierno chino ayuda a
pagar los gastos sanitarios pero por el
otro tienen que controlar el gasto
público que ocurre entonces pues veréis
el estado pone límites a la cantidad de
tratamiento subvencionado ese límite son
1700 dólares eso es lo máximo que un
hospital puede reclamarle al gobierno en
los hospitales rurales el límite es
incluso más bajo y esto en que se
traduce pues en que a partir de dos
semanas de tratamiento los hospitales
dan de baja a casi todos los enfermos
estén o no estén completamente sanos por
otro lado los hospitales están
incentivados para dejar que los
pacientes con enfermedades leves se
queden más tiempo de lo que debería de
esta forma puede justificar el cobro de
esos 1.700 dólares de subvención máxima
en otras palabras que los pacientes
graves con pocos recursos no reciben el
tratamiento que necesitan y muchos
pacientes con enfermedades leves cubren
camas que realmente no deberían cubrir
[Música]
por si todo esto fuera poco el coste de
la sanidad se está multiplicando para el
estado hasta qué punto pues más o menos
hasta los 300 mil millones de dólares al
año y diréis esto es mucho o es poco
pues para que os hagáis una idea es lo
mismo que el pib total de chile o el
equivalente a todo el presupuesto de
mexico como os podéis imaginar la
sanidad china es un sindiós así que un
buen día los gerifaltes del partido se
juntaron en una sala y encontraron una
solución mágica literalmente
ah
como os decíamos antes muchas áreas de
china no han tenido medicina moderna
hasta hace unas pocas décadas eso
significa que a día de hoy todavía hay
mucha gente que sigue creyendo en la
llamada medicina tradicional china
técnicas milenarias que tienen cero base
científica cualquier caso hasta el año
2016 había médicos que ofrecían
tratamientos tradicionales eso sí que
les exigía que antes estudiarán medicina
la medicina tradicional era como una
especialidad a mayores pero todo eso
cambió en el año 2016
en ese momento china redujo los
requisitos para ser médico tradicional
ahora basta con tener conocimientos de
medicina tradicional y tener dos médicos
que te avalen en otras palabras que no
necesitas un título médico para dar
tratamientos y recetas en el momento en
el que hacemos este vídeo ya hay más de
4000 hospitales de medicina tradicional
en china muchos pensaréis que esto es
una barbaridad pero lo cierto es que
para el gobierno chino esto es algo de
lo que he presumido atentos
china tiene ahora cuatro mil doscientos
treinta y ocho hospitales de medicina
tradicional china con 877 mil camas esta
noticia es de xinhuanet es decir el
medio oficial del partido comunista
chino en otras palabras que para el
gobierno chino todo esto de la medicina
tradicional es un orgullo y es
especialmente popular en las zonas
rurales si a día de hoy en muchos
hospitales de china están curando
algunas enfermedades con hierbas
acupuntura y taichi
por ejemplo una de las medicinas que
usan son los lagartos gekko disecados
por lo visto según dicen algunos podrían
tener propiedades para tratar tumores
para curar la disfunción eréctil algunos
utilizan la llamada viagra del himalaya
que es un hongo que crece por esta zona
su demanda se ha inflado hasta alcanzar
un precio realmente nacho vidal ya no
110 mil dólares el kilo en fin yo no soy
médico y no voy a deciros y los lagartos
disecados curan o no curan los tumores
lo que sí puedo deciros es que existe un
debate por ejemplo el ministerio de
sanidad en españa considera que es una
pseudociencia muchas asociaciones
médicas en estados unidos y europa dicen
que no tiene ninguna evidencia
científica
sin embargo la organización mundial de
la salud ha incluido algunas prácticas
como válidas para hacer diagnósticos
también es cierto que china es un país
miembro de la organización mundial de la
salud y que ha hecho todo lo posible por
que se acepte no se si ambas cosas
tendrán algo que ver pero ya sé lo que
piensan algunos bueno son remedios
naturales todo lo que viene de la
naturaleza es bueno verdad pues mucho
cuidado con la naturaleza china
[Música]
informe oficial una quinta parte del
suelo de china está contaminado para que
os hagáis una idea en el año 2013 se
descubrió que muchas cosechas de arroz
estaban contaminadas con carne carne o
que podría ser cancerígeno y este es uno
de los escándalos que hemos conocido no
olvidéis que en china no hay libertad de
expresión es decir que el gobierno
podría estar ocultando muchos más
y por supuesto no sería raro inclinar
que al igual que hay arroz contaminado
también haya hierbas medicinales
contaminadas pensadlo bien para lanzar
una pastilla al mercado hay que pasar un
montón de pruebas clínicas sin embargo
la viagra del himalaya viene
directamente del campo a tu taza de té
si esos hongos han absorbido algún
elemento es muy difícil detectarlo pero
ya sé lo que estáis pensando a ver
fonseca y todo esto que me estás
contando que tiene que ver con el
coronavirus pues atentos
[Música]
la leyenda del murciélago ya sé lo que
me vas a decir muchos y dónde está el
problema con la medicina tradicional si
no te gusta no la uses pues sí pero a la
vez no el problema está cuando alguien
deja de utilizar medicina y se echan
brazos de un charlatán
en ese momento ocurren cosas como esta
un imperio de la medicina alternativa
china blanco de las críticas después de
que los médicos concluyeron que trató
con té de azufaifa a una paciente de
cáncer de cuatro años pero ojo porque
esto no es el único problema el otro
peligro de la medicina tradicional es
ecológico si habéis oído bien ecológico
por alguna razón muchos de estos
tratamientos tradicionales requieren de
animales raros animales de los que
quedan pocos ejemplares y que de repente
se convierten en objeto de deseo y todo
el mundo se danza por ellos
ese es el caso del rinoceronte el
pangolín o el murciélago y de nuevo qué
tiene que ver todo esto con el
coronavirus pues atentos a este estudio
[Música]
aplicación rápida de los beta
coronavirus e identificación de la
medicina tradicional china como origen
potencial de los corona virus tono ticos
nos emociona este estudio sólo plantea
una hipótesis veréis esta no es la
primera vez que el mundo sufre una
epidemia por coronavirus la primera el
llamado sars surgió en 2003 también en
china el origen era un tipo de
murciélago la segunda el mes en el año
2012 surgió en arabia saudita y también
tenía un origen zoonótico en este caso
fueron los camellos pero a su vez los
camellos se habían contagiado por los
murciélagos vamos que parece que algunas
especies de murciélagos podrían ser el
huésped natural de los colom a virus
pronósticos y resulta que estas especies
de murciélagos se utilizan en la
medicina tradicional
significa esto que se ha descubierto el
origen exacto del coronavirus por
supuesto que no no sabemos cuál es el
origen exacto del coronavirus lo que sí
sabemos es quién está promoviendo que
los chinos usen animales raros para
curarse y es este señor
sin mayores esfuerzos para promover la
medicina tradicional china y todo esto
porque pues ni más ni menos que por el
dinero como la medicina tradicional
china es más barata la quieren utilizar
más según cifras oficiales chinas la
medicina tradicional rebaja a un 24 por
ciento de los gastos hospitalarios y un
12 por ciento los gastos ambulatorios
pero no sólo eso también hablamos de
nacionalismo puro y duro' veréis según
la narrativa de seeking ping la medicina
científica es simplemente medicina
occidental
[Música]
pero vamos que la medicina tradicional
es tan válida o incluso más a fin de
cuentas de quién te vas a fiar más del
método científico o de 4000 años de
historia y podría ser una prueba más de
que ese socialismo con caracteres chinos
es muy superior a ese decadente
occidente capitalista todo esto explica
que durante años china haya estado
promoviendo su medicina tradicional por
todas partes desde la organización
mundial de la salud hasta muchos medios
de comunicación y no no estamos hablando
de fake news atentos a esta noticia
coronavirus puede la medicina
tradicional china ayudar a combatir la
enfermedad esta noticia es de la 'dolce
bell que es como decir la bbc alemana es
decir hablamos de uno de los medios con
mejor reputación del mundo y por
supuesto si nos vamos a los medios
oficiales chinos encontramos cosas como
esta
un tratamiento de la medicina
tradicional china eficaz contra el
novedoso coronavirus según fuentes
oficiales pero la pregunta es es el
murciélago el causante de coronavirus
pues lo cierto es que no lo sabemos y
tal vez nunca lo sepamos solo podemos
decir una cosa si el murciélago hubiera
sido un factor en la transmisión del
coronavirus al ser humano china no lo va
a reconocer y porque lo sabemos pues por
esto
muere de coronavirus el médico chino
silenciado tras advertir del brote de
nuevo todos sois libres de formar a
vuestra propia opinión pero yo
personalmente lo último que me espero es
que una dictadura como china vaya a ser
transparente en este tema no sólo eso
espero mucha propaganda por parte de xi
jinping pensadlo bien estos últimos dos
años están siendo una pesadilla para el
régimen primero las protestas de hong
kong luego la guerra comercial de trump
y ahora el coronavirus que puede
convertirse en el chernóbil chino
[Música]
al igual que chernóbil no se trata de
ninguna conspiración nadie quería que la
central nuclear estallara pero es cierto
que la falta de medidas de seguridad y
sobre todo la falta de transparencia
propició el estallido de la central algo
parecido podría estar pasando aquí por
supuesto que no hay ninguna conspiración
detrás de todo esto ahora bien de verdad
podemos decir que china ha gestionado
esta crisis de forma responsable o tal
vez el sistema de salud chino ha podido
influir en esta catástrofe creéis que el
coronavirus va a tener consecuencias
políticas para china
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto si queréis
aprender más sobre mi sistema de salud
no olvidéis pasaros por mi canal
glóbulos azules que pasaron suscribiros
y esas cosas y ya a bueno y si queréis
que vuelva a pasarte por visual político
es para minar a fonseca abajo en los
comentarios
y como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribimos a visual polític y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]